that's recording okay my hair's not sure
what it's doing my eyelashes are not
sure what they're doing I don't know if
they're still falling out or not
Everything feels a little uncertain
right now though everything is also
going really well the sun just came out
over halfway through my radiation
treatment so fun so I said I was going
to make a video in which I go through
all the products that I bought and used
during chemo and that's exactly what
this is you already I mean there's a
title the first couple videos I posted
there were a lot of recommendations in
the comment section there which feel
free to go back and look at that I went
back through my order history on Amazon
and just put together this list of all
of the that I ordered cuz it was a
lot so hopefully this is stuff that you
can use if you are in fact going through
chemo in which I'm really sorry
that you got to do this but maybe
something here will help you through it
and if you're looking to get something
for someone that is about to go through
chemo there's likely something in this
list that you can send should we
normalize chemo Registries the way that
we do for babies and weddings I feel
like there should be medical Registries
I also don't have like an Amazon
storefront or anything should I do that
I don't know it feels a little like too
much capitalism but also I like looking
at other people's storefronts how do you
even get one I don't know that requires
research and this is how we abandon our
ideas I'm going to link as much as I can
down below most of if not all of this
was found on Amazon and apologies that I
know I know people don't like Amazon I
also just don't like cancer and this was
just easy for me to get stuff I'm going
to try to go quickish let's start with
toiletries these are sort of by
categories but not really across the
board you want to go with gentle
unscented toiletries they tell you that
you will get sensitive to sense and ooh
I got sensitive to sense so I found this
gentle face wash I so badly wanted to
say can you see it can you see it can
you see it but there's just too many
things and that that will become awful
for everyone involved just imagine in
your own mind that that's happening Ro
POS it's a gentle face cleanser I still
have a ton left that I'm still using I
really really like it it's very um milky
have we discussed that milky is not a
great word to use or say sidebar
basically any unscented cleanser works
but this one uh had
30,000 decent ratings on Amazon so I did
I followed the group and it doesn't just
the point like a like a Milky pudding
like if you took a bowl of pudding and
you put some milk in it and you mixed it
around and then you I don't know what
products I should be normally using and
then my skin got different during chemo
so I really didn't know what products to
use so I just Googled Mo friendly face
products and I found this Lindy skin l i
n di this is their Lindy fight backpack
which is very cute 69 reviews literally
can't not so this is a great gift idea
for someone that you know might be going
through chemo cuz this is already in
like a gift siiz pack thing words comes
with sample sizes of like body lotion
body wash Citrus face serum lavender
face serum face moisturizer soothing
balm and face wash I especially loved
their face serums the Citrus face serum
and the lavender face serum for some
reason weren't too intense of a smell
for me so I was fine with those and it
is designed for use after chemo or
radiation Bing Bang Boom there you go
it's sample sizes so it's like Costco
skin care give them some samples see if
they want to buy the fulls sizee item I
don't know what to do with my hands when
I'm not like holding a product this is
good other face products I've mentioned
these before bah is a brand that came up
when I looked up chemo friendly face
product they're a little bit more
expensive than drugstore face products I
love them I use them the entire time and
the background of this brand is two
sisters when Lauren was diagnosed with
aute myoid leukemia her sister Sarah
became her stem cell owner and saved
Lauren's life as Lauren recovered
Sarah's Str able to find naturally yet
effective products to by Lauren's cancer
ravage skin so she decided to devel own
formulas and with this active sisterly
love skare by Sarah was born so this was
made specifically to treat cancer ravage
skin sounds dramatic but you know
Cancer's not not dramatic do I need to
say that none of this is sponsored at
all just stuff stuff this is just stuff
I use I've talked about this before too
Brian Joseph's lash and brow
conditioning gel I got a message from
someone that said they use this during
their chemo and their eyelashes and
eyebrows stayed on it doesn't work for
everyone but I tried it and my lashes
you know some of them stayed on it's a
unique blend of natural ingredients that
could be anything I did absolutely zero
research on this I went wholly with the
recommendation of a complete stranger
and put a clear liquid product you know
directly next to what some might
consider one of the most important body
parts on the body my eyes I've never had
the best decision making skills and
recently I stopped using it because I
thought that two months after chemo
would end the actual like hair falling
out situation but I think some of my
eyelashes started falling out right
after I stopped using it so I've been
using it again just to make sure these
little guys don't give me any surprises
be's overnight lip treatment everyone
uses that l l l l everyone uses I myself
included I use this at night as well I
have a couple of these all around my
house but someone turned me on to the
it's be's overnight lip situation it's
fantastic it's $8 versus 24 for the
longerie version I loved it scentless
deodorant I've always been like why do
they even make scentless deodorants if
you're trying to get rid of a smell are
you supposed to put a better smell on
top of it and then I got chemo and I was
like I simply cannot handle anything Lum
who sponsors our podcast this might get
weird sent some unscented deodorant if
you don't know their brand they make
whole body deodorant which I think I
manifested maybe like a decade ago I
loved their unscented whole body
deodorant I still wear it every day now
even though I hardly sweat during that
time so I often was like do I even need
deodorant and then just for my own peace
of mind I I did it and this is what I
use riveting okay now let's see what
that mouth do you're going to want some
special toothpaste and special mouthwash
your mouth gets up potenti gets
up mine
got moderately up I use this
biotine fluoride toothpaste used a
couple different types of toothpaste
during this time but this is the one
that I just ended up sticking to and
reordering I ended up using prevention
oncology mouthwash it has a very weird
taste to it it's not offensive in its
flavor it's just different this one is
specifically formulated for patients
undergoing oncology treatment so this
one worked for me and and this helps
prevent the mouth sores that are a
common side effect fun right where this
is fun these are fun things to talk
about right is there a way that I could
make this more fun there's also
physicist oncology cream and lip balm I
use this lip balm which worked really
well for me and then this oncology cream
I still have I didn't really use so I
can't speak entirely to it but it has
great ratings on Amazon it's for
stressed skin nice just to have on hand
I didn't use a ton of body cream but if
you do boom physicist oncology cream not
the sexiest packaging but I don't think
anyone in your house will touch it so
you don't have to worry about that how
do we make this medical packaging sexier
maybe that's what's missing here just
because we're going through chemo
doesn't mean we don't want our sexy
capitalistic products marketed in a away
that makes us feel young
and I was going to say like we're going
to live forever but you know maybe the
medical packaging is great and then for
hair products I really minimized how
much I wash my hair because I was doing
the cold capping and I was trying not to
stress my hair out too much by washing
it so I hardly hardly wash my hair but
when I did wash it I was trying to use
vegamore grow products it's supposed to
strengthen your hair and give you
thicker fuller looking hair however I
did slide into their DMS after chemo and
they sent me a bunch of their products
cuz they're you know expensive I've been
using them now as I'm in the hair regrow
phase taking their biotin gummies
shampoo and conditioner lash and brow
serums and it's been going really well
so vegamore thank you so much ever want
to send me more free oh I just open
arms at the front door for the delivery
guy waiting all right we just got
through the toiletries let's move into
the category I'm calling nausea mhm
obviously you can Google what to get for
nausea related to chemo and there's a
billion bits of information so many of
you recommended getting Ginger candies
and gingin which I did I honestly didn't
use them a ton thankfully my nausea
wasn't out of control the majority of
the time and the nausea medication that
they gave me worked fairly well if you
know someone with cancer going through
chemo it does not hurt to get them some
sort of tummy soothing candy mentally it
was just very nice to know that I had
all of this on hand and in case I
needed it I even went so far as to buy
an anti- nausea wristband like what
people get when they go on cruises there
was a point before I got officially
diagnosed with ciff that I busted this
baby out and really tried to use it cuz
the nausea had gotten to a point that
was ooh nasty I just couldn't figure out
the right way to use it for me it comes
with good ratings so it might work for
you just throwing that out there that
that's a possibility I mean who says you
can't accessorize while you're going
through chemo okay that does it for the
the nausea stuff let's move on to
clothing SL blankets one of the best
purchases that I made was Port access
hoodies off of Amazon now my port was in
my arm notice I said was because it's
not there anymore but it's sore and a
lot of people's ports will be up on
their chest but they still make clothing
both for arm ports and for chest ports
all of the nurses thought it was so cool
who doesn't want to be told their outfit
is cool when they're going to
chemotherapy I'm Still Human I'm still
ravaged by insecurities so that felt
really nice also just the functionality
of it was topnotch then we have S lined
beanies like this one I'm wearing here
obviously there's a ton of head wear
options out there someone suggested
satin or silk line beanies and this was
20 bucks I bought two of them it's so
lovely I should be wearing Silkline
beanies cancer aside feel so nice on my
head and they're so gentle on my hair if
you're dealing with hair shedding if
you've lost all your hair or if you're
currently like growing it back these
stilk lined beanies are so nice and
gentle a comfy uh uh I thought this was
one of the greatest pieces of clothing
development that has happened in the
Fashion World way before Kemo I'm so
glad that I already had one on Deck
going into this because I wore the
out of this I also bought this robe that
was recommended and that was extremely
comfortable as well I love that when I'm
opting for a robe but for some reason
I'm just more comfy in my comfy comfy
like get in my DMs what can we do
together I am preaching the good word of
the shapeless oversized blanket
sweatshirt as a fledgling member of the
unfortunate cancer Club help a grow out
but this to me is like the ideal gift
that you could get someone that is going
through chemo it's got a little bit of
light-heartedness to it but it's fun
functionality is actually so seriously
wonderful and there's tons of like
knockoff versions of it on Amazon as
well see comfy I wouldn't throw that in
if you slid into the DMS and you worked
with a girl Comfort is key you want
comfortable things head to toe
comfortable things if you're trying to
get something for someone that you know
is diagnosed and you're at a loss start
with something comfortable a blanket a
comfy a sweatshirt sweatpants warm socks
also you probably saw this blanket in
all of my chemotherapy photos on
Instagram this was gifted by my friend
christe this is from a brand called
Johnny was this was the most comfortable
blanket I got so many compliments on
this first of all I brought it to every
single infusion even though they give
you blankets there they can be a little
scratchy and starchy so this was just
like the first thing I packed in the car
every morning that we had to go it comes
with its own bag to carry so it's like
made for this it's made for adorning
beautiful homes but you know my body
some say is a beautiful home thank you
Christie for this absolutely beautiful
blanket such an insanely gorgeous gift
on so many levels but the idea of
getting someone a travel blanket I think
is a great gift now let's move into food
and drink make this a little bit more
splashy and fun ooh food and drink well
you feel like you're dying no it's okay
it's going to be okay the big takeaway
is it's going to be okay even if you
feel like at least you'll have your
things right number one you got to stay
hydrated liquid IV I bought bags and
bags of this and I still now I'm in a
habit where I wake up first thing fill a
bottle with water and liquid IV and it's
my go-to in the morning while I have my
matcha or whatever lightly caffeinated
beverage that isn't coffee liquid IV get
into it I like to think that the liquid
IVs help me from not needing more actual
IVs love that that for me and speaking
of big girl bottles this Tumblr Trend
couldn't come out a better time for me
getting cancer I bought this Sleek
modern Tumblr cup that I love very much
it's currently in the dishwasher because
do not forget to wash your big girl
bottle they'll get big girl bacteria and
you'll be in big girl trouble one week I
left it at the oncology building during
my hydration session and I went home and
I bought the exact same one again I got
the color almond Birch and I just feel
like ooh a leak girly that has all of
her faculties in order seemingly Ade
this was huge for me and this you will
absolutely want to talk to your doctor
and or there is usually a medical
nutritionist or dietician working in
hospital settings that if you have
access to talk to them about it I had
this awesome woman named Alex that would
come and do rounds on the floors during
our infusions and she would just talk to
me about my diet and my gut and what was
going going on and try to help and she
recommended enterade in the very
beginning of the process I was like yeah
yeah okay I bought some still but I
didn't start using it till after I got
SEI and it made a massive difference
people I know that had cancer a few
years ago hadn't even heard of this so I
think it's relatively new formulated to
reduce the GI side effects from
treatment entrate is formulated to be
used leading up to during and post
treatment while symptoms last the camera
got too hot and it shut off like girl
same I keep getting these hot flashes
what was I talking about ENT a I think
it's about 50 bucks for a 12pack I know
crazy but life got crazy for me when I
got SEI I just needed help with my
stomach so bad this became like
religious to me I would wake up every
day make my liquid IV water and drink an
enterade before I made breakfast which
Speaking of breakfast zodiac pancake mix
you guys know that I got hyper fixated
on Banana Pancakes during treatment and
you know what I still like making
pancakes it hasn't fully ruined it for
me I don't know if it's the Amnesia or
just my inherent ability to
compartmentalize my mom introduced me to
Kodiak pancake mix it's just got protein
in it and I was having a hard time
putting protein in my body and my body
desperately needed protein and they make
all different flavors you can get
pumpkin I got birthday cake flavor and
blueberry electrolyte drinks having
those on hand was really great just when
I needed extra hydration in my body the
best way to think about this is to think
of it as like the worst hangover of your
life what do you need when you're
hungover start there and then build up
Kate Farms shakes okay these shakes were
also recommended to me by the
nutritionist at the hospital these are
nutrition shakes they're high in
calories they're dense but they're small
they're like a dumb gymnast very petite
very dense they're designed for people
that need to get a bunch of good stuff
in their body in a very efficient way
sometimes I could tolerate them
sometimes I felt a little nauseous about
them but they're easy to reach forward
to have on hand you don't have to think
about do I need to make myself something
in all honesty they're delicious it was
my problem not them bone broth buy them
by the box full you can drink bone broth
straight out of the little container
someone recommended to mix it in with
rice when I cooked rice and that was
awesome it's got all kinds of good
for you like I feel like gwenth paltro
like bathes in it and then drinks the
bathat when she's done is that a
reference to the movie I feel like I
can't say the word bathwater now without
being an accidental reference to a movie
that I haven't seen I don't know if
talking about bath water is off limits
right now but I we don't need to talk
about bath water anymore bone broth it
really works when you're not feeling
great it's got a lot of nutrients it's
got whatever the good stuff is that your
body needs to function well in it it
adds a little bit of flavor when you
will probably be eating extremely
flavorless Foods a probiotic again this
is something you need to talk to your
doctor or your nutritionist about
specifically this got really recommended
to me during treatment especially after
I got diagnosed with Ceda a friend of a
friend recommended this specific one to
me Ultra Flora balance um because they
had also gotten sediff while treating
breast cancer and started using this and
it helped them out so I started using
this and it has really helped me out I
take it every morning again in that
morning ritual I would take this my
enterade my liquid IV and then I would
wait a half hour and I would make my
pancakes and that was how I started
every morning and there's a billion I
feel like probiotic choices out there so
again talk to your doctor and your
nutritionist about how a probiotic could
be right for you okay that was some food
and drink stuff now last category
miscellaneous discomfort ooh this camera
is also going to die again a regular
thermometer I bought two of those little
thermometer guns that go go up to your
head we had such difficulty with them
the entire time that I finally just
bought a regular ass under the tongue
thermometer those little half guns that
you put up to your forehead and your
temples and wherever you can find a spot
those were giving me temperature
readings all over the place which was
stressing me out because one of the
biggest things to look for is whether or
not you start to run the temperature if
you start to get a temperature you have
to go to a hospital immediately when you
don't have a thermometer that gives you
consistent readings it will drive you
crazy so spent money on these fancy new
fangled high tech thermometers and ended
up going back to the regular thermometer
so make sure you have a thermometer on
hand a blood pressure monitor this we
bought as a necessity after the whole
seed of debacle in which my blood
pressure was borderline unconscious and
I love this little thing it straps on
your wrist like a little slap bracelet
and you push the button and it just
starts to tighten around your wrists and
read your blood pressure this thing was
so helpful I don't know if any of you
grew up watching Inspector Gadget and
Penny had that watch thing I like
idolized that growing up and so it just
made me feel a little bit like Penny
from Inspector
Gadget an eye cooling mask this was so
wonderful for headaches hot flashes I
had a lot of eye sensitivity an eye
cooling mask um just in life I think is
pretty good to have l a numbing cream
ooh for your Port this was fantastic
load up on some light aaine numbing
cream the morning before you go to your
infusions slather that Port area in it
and then put a Band-Aid over it really
cake it on there like your port's a
little cupcake and you want to ice it
that stuff helped me so so much you're
going to be hooked up to an IV for hours
and hours and it might feel okay in the
beginning but it will feel more
uncomfortable so get that numbing cream
what do I do when something's
uncomfortable I numb myself and I
used to do it a lot of different
unhealthy ways in the past and this is
probably the healthiest numbing for
discomfort I've ever done in my life
heating pads just another nice thing to
have on hand I got gifted a heating pad
and it was great I still use it now with
my sore muscles from getting my port
removed heating pad can't go wrong by
gifting a heating pad we're all adults I
think that's a really nice adult gift
actually okay this is going to die soon
but my last two things blue blocker
glasses for sensitive eyes and a journal
or diary for writing your symptoms
having a written record of your symptoms
helps you track and know what to expect
for upcoming recovery episodes and also
it's just good your brain is going to
get crazy to have things written down
okay my equipment is about to die but I
hope this was helpful I'll try to link
as much stuff as I can down below thank
you guys so much for watching let me
know if you have any other questions
around the whole cancer experience that
might be helpful to make videos of
moving forward
and if you guys recommend anything else
leave it in the comments down below so
that we can all use these resources
together okay man I can tell that I'm
healing cuz my armpits are
sweating and that's it well thanks for
watching guys I don't know